this whisk you were coming down and then
suddenly there was this sense of the
visual field splitting and something
lying behind it I never had exactly that
I remember I had a very anomalous DMT
trip once I its was sort of like that it
was here's what it was it was really a
strange one I can't remember where I was
but anyway I smoked the DMT and I
expected to see the chrysanthemum and
everything as I described and instead
when I opened my eyes or when I not when
I opened my eyes but when I broke
through into the space I seemed to see
red flocked wallpaper in a fleur-de-lis
on a wall of some sort that looked like
red flocked wallpaper and as I looked at
this I dropped my head forward and there
was a water fountain spigot of the kind
that you depress and it shoots a stream
of water coming out of a marble basin
and it was just perfectly realistic and
then above it and then I saw above it
was this flocked red wallpaper and as I
was trying to get my bearings in this
situation I turned like 90 degrees and
there was a curtain of red velvet and I
walked through the curtain and there was
a DMT trip up on a huge CinemaScope
screen and I just sat down in the aisle
seat and then the trip happened but but
there had been this peculiar hesitation
where I was apparently in some art deco
movie palace somewhere on the Fourier
landing at the water fountain and then
and I never quite understood what that
was about or why it happened but it had
the same quality of the
pardon curtain revealing the trip
somehow already in progress one of the
things that goes on in DMT that sort of
God is you perceive your body geometry
differently you seem to have an
infantile body you can tell that your
head is massive and your body is small
and your arms and legs are short and at
times we've played around with the idea
that once you smoked DMT all subsequent
trips are like journeys back to this
first trip it's as though you can you
open a nexus in time in your personality
and then every subsequent trip you just
return to this to this open place
there's a very funny feeling about it
that is something about the past
something about time it's hard to put
your finger on I remember one time I
mean this is more explicit but these are
the more anomalous trips I remember once
about must have been 25 years ago a long
time ago I smoked DMT with these two
women both of which I had had a
relationship with in the past and I was
living with one over them at the time
and we smoked the DMT together and and I
opened my eyes at one point and one of
these women was just aging
furiously paint her hair was turning
white her teeth were turning in her
mouth her skin was melting and any was
it was absolutely startling and the
other one was getting younger at an
equal rate going you know 25 21 17 16 4
and it was like it was nos it didn't
feel like it was about my relationship
to them or what I thought about a over B
it looked more profound than that I mean
it looked like one of them was going
forward in time and one of them was
going backward in time and it was right
in front of me and I didn't say anything
I was shocked I didn't know what in the
world you could say I just gave at this
spectacle and then closed my eyes and on
to something else